hi there today we're looking at
extracting training data from
large language models by what appears to
be
a big collaboration between corporations
and academic institutions there are
almost
as many affiliations here as their
authors
so this is joint work between you know
as you can see
many many um sort of institutions
and it is a pretty cool paper
so the high level topic is that these
authors take
large language models as the title says
right here
and um trained large language models
specifically and they're able to extract
training data
just from the trained model in fact just
from the black box
access to the trained model and and not
only are they able to extract
training data they are able to extract
pieces of training data
sort of verbatim that have appeared
only very few times in the training data
uh
they that's what they call a form of
memorization
so they're able to extract these
with a kind of pretty clever attack so
if you look at this
prime example right here they are able
to query
gpt2 in this case which is one of these
large language models
to output this piece of text and the
black
stuff here is by the authors to uh
protect the
sort of privacy of this individual right
here this is
though this is a real piece of text that
they actually got out
and you can verify that um so they're
able to extract this
just from gpt2 and um
needless to say this has consequences
for security and
privacy and so on because
if you train one of these models with
let's say
internal or private data user data and
so on
you have to be worried that these models
are going to just
output that data again on the other end
and potentially leak information um
this of course has not been a problem
that much
so far if you know once we just trained
image classifiers and so on but here
especially with only black box access
this seems like
it has some some consequences so we'll
go
over the paper we'll go over the the
attack or the technique the author's
device which is i think pretty clever
um we'll go over sort of the the results
that they get
from using this on a gpt-2 and
we'll go over my opinion of the paper
which um
i can already tell you my ultimate
opinion is that
the the tack is cool the concerns are
valid but the paper is probably written
a little bit more scary than it
ultimately seems in fact i find that the
results
uh the the actual results of this paper
fairly
okay like fairly um
[Music]
promising uh and and sort of
straightforward not that scary and
also the paper is interesting from
another perspective namely
uh from the perspective of what it tells
us about these language models and how
they work
and it it sort of strengthens a number
of hypotheses that i've put forward in
my video about gpt3
about how these models work and and
that's also fairly cool to see in this
paper
so we're going to jump in here and as
always
if you like content like this don't
hesitate to share it out
or subscribe and subscribe i should say
uh
if you're not yet all right so
they say it has become common to publish
large so billion parameter language
models that have been trained on private
data sets
this paper demonstrates that in such
settings
an adversary can perform a training data
extraction attack to recover
individual training examples by querying
the language model
right so we have a we already have quite
a bit of information right here
so large language models um
have been of course trending with you
know especially since gpt3
but at least since um since the
the advent of the transformers bert and
so on
though bert isn't exactly a language
model so language models
are models that per given a piece of
text
predict the next word let's let's so
easy as that or they predict a
probability distribution over the next
word so if you say a
cat sat on
so that's the input the language model
would give you a probability
distribution over the next word so the
next word might be
the or the next word might be a or the
next because of next two and so on and
it will sort of give you
a probability distribution over each of
these words that kind of looks like a
face
um it will tell you how likely each next
word is and so on and then you can
sample from it
you can sort of choose one of those
words and then go on
and you can evaluate the likelihood of
entire sequences and so on so gpt-3
is one of those large language models
and these large language models they've
been
of course since they are large we know
that they also need
a lot of data to be trained on so a
large language model would take like a
giant piece you know a database of
training data which is
scraped from the internet usually so
this is
too much to simply be curated by humans
they just let scrapers run over the
internet
then they use this to train the model
whatever that is
in gpt uh gpt2 in this case
and gpt2 will then be a trained model
so you you sort of throw the training
data away
and you simply say this is our model now
we're going to publish this
right now the problem is if there is a
piece of data in here
that is kind of secret and you you think
well i it's just one piece of data like
how much can
how much can go wrong right the problem
is if
i can inspect gpt2 and recover
this exact piece of training data so
that gpt2 will output that exact piece
right that is uh is a problem now they
they make some good points here
this notion of a piece of training data
and
what it means to memorize a piece of
training data and what it means to
extract one is fairly fuzzy and they go
quite a bit deeper in this paper so they
have kind of strict definitions
they say we demonstrate our attack on
gpd2
a language model trained on scraped
scrapes of the public internet and are
able to extract hundreds of verbatim
text sequences from the model's training
data
these extracted examples include public
personally identifiable informations
so names phone numbers and email
addresses as you
saw on the right here irc conversations
code 128-bit uuids
and so on so so they are able to extract
all of these
things from the trained model right
and this you can already see that how
how this can become a problem they say
our attack is possible
even though each of the above sequences
are included
in just one document in the training
data
and this notion this notion of
memorization here
and when it is dangerous they correctly
say that this is
only dangerous of course if the training
example
is contained in let's say only one piece
of training data because
if something is contained in thousands
of pieces of training data it's
you know it's okay to memorize that
right if a name of like
some famous person um is memorized and
maybe that the addre like
like that the president of the usa lives
at the white house that it is not a
secret
right so it is okay if your language
model remembers that
because it probably occurs in many
training data
points however if something is contained
in just
one document right and the model
remembers it then that is you know kind
of true memorization
it it is not maybe or you know it's
probably not learning anything from that
data point it's simply memorizing it
uh to make its training loss lower
so that's the the case on the right
right here
though i have to say uh this
as i said it's written a bit more scary
so
they don't exactly say that this name
and phone number is contained in just
one document
and they they also say like this is of
course this is pop this is on the public
internet gpt2's training data was
scraped from the public internet so here
is
sort of my first investigation into this
of course you can google this and
you'll find it um you'll find this and
even though you know the blacking out
here also is a little bit of
i think it's a little bit gimmicky
because i don't see a problem
with disclosing this particular piece of
information and i'll show
you why so when you search for it you'll
find
the nist home page you'll find a
cryptographic algorithm validation
program
and you'll find that this is a
description of a software implementation
and here is the personally identifiable
information
you can see this is a corporate
address so this is an address of a
corporation
and the contact information is a
corporate contact it's a corporate email
address it's a corporate phone number
and so on this is the exact
thing right here and you know with
with respect to it only being present
once in the training data so if you
actually search for
if you complete the name here and search
for this
you'll find many many many
many many results now i don't know how
many of these results are actually from
you know in the gpt training data no one
knows that
except open ai so there's two google
pages of results
but oh google has d sort of deduplicated
some of them
and now if i click on all there are
many there are 9 000 results for this
and they are not all the same oh no no
so if you look at a bunch of those
you'll see that they are
almost the same but here
at the bottom as you can see
this changes so you know depending on
your scraper
these all count as separate websites
and therefore i'm not so sure that this
particular piece of information here
is contained only once
plus it is a corporate contact so again
so to my point the paper might be
written a bit more scary
than um then it
ultimately turns out to be uh though
you know you have to you have to make
two different points like this
particular piece of information
uh yes it might be written a bit more
scary and gimmicky with the
with the blacked out stuff however right
the paper has a point namely that if
let's say you as a company do this on
internal data
it might very well be and they they do
have examples where they
reproduce data from just one document
but even it might be that something like
this
happens to you internally where you sort
of
maybe in your internal document base you
sort of do quasi-duplicate a document
with the same information over and over
and and that's not de-duplicated and
then your language model sort of
memorizes that
um so it's quite it it has a point the
paper
that's that's what i'm trying to say i
hope that's clear
all right so we'll get to the results in
a bit i hope i've already given you some
sort of a taste for
what you can expect so first of all they
go into language models into sort of the
definition of language models
and the language model here is simply
framed as a model that can
sort of give you a um
a probability of a sequence of text in
sort of a stepwise fashion so always
probability of next word given the
previous
words and you can evaluate that
right so the access to the model that
they assume here
is access to let's say the logits of the
model or the output distribution
of the model um they say they use gpt2
um because it's uh trained
on large piece of text but it's also you
can you can evaluate it it's not
as slow i guess as gpt3 and it's
publicly available uh however
the trading data to gpt2 is not publicly
available
but they do have someone of open ai on
the paper here
and this person at openai made like
mate they could sort of query the open
ai
person to make sure a given piece of
text that they find
is or isn't in the training date of gpt2
so that's how they they work uh so that
one per the openai person acts as an api
for the training data right so they
they do um they define their attacks
here
so they do a lot of uh things to
to uh set up cleanly what they do right
here
so they have two points right here there
is
this notion of memorization
okay so there's they say there are many
ways to define memorization in language
modeling in this particular
piece of work they say it is
okay to memorize some stuff they say
language models must for example
memorize the correct spelling of
individual words
right because the words are made of word
pieces and the language model needs to
output that
so that's fine if it memorizes this
indeed there is an entire area of
research that analyzes neural networks
as repositories of memorized knowledge
for example when gpt2 is prompted to
complete the sentence my address is one
main street san francisco ca
it generates the next token 94107
a correct zip code for san francisco in
california
they say while this is clearly
memorization in some abstract form
we aim to formalize our definition of
memorization in order to restrict it to
cases that we might consider
unintended okay so so memorization as
such
isn't bad what is bad is what they call
here
the identic memorization of text
so eidetic memorization of text
is when the model memorizes something
that only appears very few times in the
training
so they say we first define what it
means for a model
to x to have knowledge of a string our
definition is loosely inspired
if a model f knows a string
if s can be extracted by interacting
with the model so if you can
input whatever you need to input and the
model outputs
s then the uh you say that model
knows s right so if s
is a piece of training data then you say
the model memorizes s the model has
memorized it
so here they say a string is extractable
from a language model if there is a
prefix and the prefix here is the input
to the model
such that if you input that model the
output will be the will be the string
and then they define this eidetic
memorization
respectively they define k eidetic
a string s is k iodic i have no clue
whether i pronounce this correctly
k identic memorized by a language model
f if f if s is extractable from
f so that's memorization and s
appears in at most k examples in the
training
data okay so if this
address of this person only appeared
twice
but you could extract it verbatim from
the language model then that would be an
example of
two eidetic memorization okay because k
in that case would be
two because it appears twice in the
training data
though they um they also they are not
clear what they mean by
examples in the training data because
usually this training data is sort of
chunked to make it fit into the language
model and so on
and i think they do this on a document
basis so they would consider
something like this here one example
right and then a different
document a different example so if you
have like
um for example if you have these irc
conversations that they
are able to extract so they claim here
they are able to extract
irc conversations or they're able to
extract
the usernames of the irc conversations
right the usernames might appear
hundreds or
thousands of time because they chat with
each other and it will all be
you know in one document but the
document will be so long they will
actually be
chunked into different training data
pieces maybe i don't know
i i don't know exactly
what it means to be an example right
here
um but they do the example for sure
for sure that piece of text can appear
more than
once even if it is only in one example
in fact they
they actually analyze this situation
all right so we've defined that this is
the chi
these k eidetic memorization that's what
we're looking for
that's sort of the problematic regime if
k is very small and the extreme k
is one one piece of training data
contains
a string and we can extract the string
at from the trained
language model they also say that
for any given k memorizing longer
strings is also intuitively more harmful
than
shorter ones so this
kind of makes sense and they even they
even go
into sort of corner cases they say mid
certain pathological corner cases for
example many language model when
prompting with the sequence
repeat the following sentence and then
you give a sentence we'll do so
correctly
uh this technically allows any string to
be known under our definition
but they they of course don't do that
they assume they don't know the training
data so they can't just say repeat the
following sentence and so on
but you do see that it is fairly hard
actually to even define
the problem right here even though we as
humans have
a sort of a an intuition what it means
uh
for a language model to unintentionally
or un to do unintended memorization
right so the adversary's objective here
is to extract memorized training data
from the model
the strength of the attack is measured
by how private
so uh how k-identic a particular example
is
stronger attacks extract more examples
in total
and examples with lower values of k
they say we do not aim to extract
targeted pieces of training data
but rather indiscriminately extract
training data
while targeted attacks have the
potential to be more adversarially
harmful
our goal is to study the ability of
language models to memorize
data generally not to create an attack
that can be operationalized by real
adversaries to target
specific users so you can see that
here they simply want some training data
they don't really care uh what it is
they simply want to get some so they're
going to search for sort of the easiest
to get
training data and that so they frame it
as
yeah we don't want to devise an attack
that can attack individual users
but there is a different component to it
so if
you had to sort of guess the password
of any particular user that would be you
know
fairly fairly hard however
if you had to guess a password that was
used by any user
um it's fairly easy right
even if you discard the fact that most
of people use password as password and
so on if
if people would just uniformly sample
words from the dictionary as their
password
uh still you'd have a decent chance of
figuring out
a password right um you have a decent
chance of figuring out
you know not super high entropy things
like maybe
credit cards you'd have a decent chance
of figuring out the credit card number
uh just by guessing one
so this is the regime we are in here and
it's entirely different regime
i think if you try to attack individual
users
essentially what they're going to do
right here is
they're going to say look there's
training data
right here now some training data
these models can extract a pattern from
right
if and this is what we do with machine
learning right we say okay
this this data right here they they all
have like some pattern and this data
right here is some pattern and you can
learn from this and
it has some patterns so the machine
learns to sort of abstract from
extranging data samples and so on
but here is a data point that doesn't
really fall into any of these
categories so what the model will do is
it will simply say well this is its sort
of own little group
i'll remember that i can extract some
pattern from here and from here but i
can't extract any pattern from here
but i need to get my loss down so i'll
just remember that
you know individual piece of training
data and that's exactly what we can
recover
with this sort of attacks these
individual
pieces that aren't really
don't really have anything close there
is not really a pattern to it so the
best the model can do
is remember that it doesn't mean
that with this attack you're going to
get this piece of data
or this piece of data right so if your
personal
identifiable information is sort of
falls into some kind of regular pattern
um
it's it's likely to be more safe against
an attack like this
that's why they for example are able to
extract these sort of uuids
or or urls with random strings in them
because random strings have no pattern
right
so they are likely to be out here away
from the other training examples where
the best the model can do is actually
remember the thing
rather than extract a pattern now
the other example here with this
personally identifiable information i
believe that's just
because it appears a lot of times
honestly
not because there is no pattern but
because it appears so many times that
the model simply you know it's it's
why should it extract a pattern when it
appears so often it can just
you know remember it like a famous
person's name seems to be
an address that's important if it
appears so often i guess from the point
of view of the model
so that's that's sort of what this does
again it extracts indiscriminately it
doesn't mean that the attack can be
leveraged
to you know get any training date to
sample back
it's still worrisome but you have to
take
into account uh another thing that
that is really um sticking out in this
paper is the amount
of hedging that this paper does uh
this this um
almost in every paragraph but certainly
in every subsection
there is like hedging hedging against
you know why
it is okay to publish this research um
and so on so you know when they say our
attack target
is is is gpt2 we select gpg2 is a nearly
perfect target
from an ethical standpoint the model and
the data are public
so any memorized data we extract is
already public
and so on um and they do this in
in every piece of text and
you know in my video about broader
impact statements that was exactly my
my point these large corporations right
if many
many of these authors i think a fair
amount of work
went into framing this research such
that it sort of
can't get attacked from you know people
concerned about
if you know ethical considerations when
releasing research like this and this is
clearly research that can be leveraged
you know for
for bad if you will um but
since these you know companies have
a lot of resources and and and they're
you know can put many people on this can
devote a fair bit of amount of um
of work into framing the problem uh
that can be mitigated whereas if you
know some lonely phd student
would do the same research right here
the exact same research i
very doubtful it would be uh received as
well
as this piece right here and in my
opinion
as i already said in that video this
just sort of
shifts you know a bit more power to
these
large institutions that sort of can
afford
the framing right here they don't have
to change anything about their research
um but the rest of us do
all right rant over let's continue
so they they're going to do this in two
different
steps right here and they have a diagram
yes they have a diagram so first
um they do this in two steps
step one they query the model they have
different queries
right but they just sort of generate
data from the model so they generate
lots of data
right here from the model
then they select somehow they select
from the model
a subset that they think these could be
memorized training examples
then they do de-duplicate it they select
again and then they check okay this is
it's fairly fairly easy workflow so step
one
is generate a bunch of data that you
think
could be uh memorized
and then step two check whether you find
these samples in the internet because
all of gpt2's training data comes from
the internet
um if you can find them on the internet
verbatim
right that probably means gpd2 as
remember like the likelihood that it
verbatim remembers you know a uuid
um that wasn't in its training data is
almost
zero so yeah this this goes by manual
internet search so respect to
these authors who have done this they
start out with some
fairly fairly weak
baseline which is they simply generate
the large quantity of data
by unconditionally sampling and then
they predict which output contains
memorized text by simply analyzing the
likelihood
so whatever text the model finds
highly likely
they they they think that could be
memorized because
if you provide a model with training
data and you ask it
to reduce its loss on the training data
it will
assign highest likelihood to the
training data
that's you know just that's how these
models work
so they assume that um
[Music]
if a model has high likelihood or low
perplexity
that's the sort of same thing um except
yeah so you can see here if the
perplexity is low then the model is not
very surprised by the sequence and has
assigned
on average a high probability to each
subsequent token in the sequence
and if that happens they say this could
be
memorized
this is obviously obviously very very
very simple
say um this simple baseline extraction
attack can find a wide variety of
memorized content
for example gpt2 memorizes the entire
text of the mit public license
as well as the user guidelines of von
life an online streaming site while this
is memorization
it is only k-i-retic memorization for a
large value of k
these licenses occur thousands of times
okay
the most interesting examples include
the memorization of popular
individuals twitter handles or email
addresses
in fact all memorized content we
identify this baseline setting is likely
to have appeared
in the training data set many times so
here they say it doesn't really work if
you just sample
and then look at what's most likely
because
yes this will be memorized but it is
sort of a non-problematic
um form of memorization like famous
people's twitter handles
this is like famous people's names at
this point right so
now they go about improving it okay so
they improve both steps they improve
step
one uh where are we
no it's down here they improve step one
by doing one of two things either
you want your temperature to decay so in
this sampling
when you sample from the model you have
a temperature that you sample
from and you can decrease that over time
so at the beginning you can let the
model explore a bit but then
you can you can decrease it and that's
so the that sorry the the goal of
changing step one
is to create a more diverse set of
generations
right so you can sample with high
temperature at the beginning
and then decrease it over time okay uh
such such that you still get sort of
high likelihood sequences but you get
different ones so you start off
differently
and then you go into the high likelihood
regime
the second way they change this is what
they do is they
go to the internet again so they go to
the world wide web
which is okay
i'm terrible at drawing the globe with
okay they go to the world wide web
and they just get pieces of text from
the internet so they get a website
and they just take some tiny substring
from here
from this and they use that as the input
to their model
and that's sort of to get more diverse
predictions so if you
input a short prefix that you found
somewhere on the internet
and then let the model continue that
generates you of wide diverse variety
of pieces of text okay so that's how
they
up the the how many different samples
the model generates
because in the initial experiments they
found that the model will
sort of output the same things over and
over again if you simply
query it unconditionally so either high
temperature or conditioned on internet
text
the second step is sort of what i find
the clever step
so here they have to before they simply
said whatever has high likelihood that's
what we
think is memorized but of course
a lot of these will not be you know with
low k
memorized a lot of them will simply be
high likelihood because they're actually
likely so they say okay when
when is when are we in this situation so
let's say here is the
here is our data set okay
and here is the the mit public license
is here and it you know appears like
billion billion billion times so this
data point is like
ginormous it's all you know the mit
public license
and here is our outlier data point now
this model will extract patterns let's
say from this
and this is a pattern and it will assign
a single pattern
to the mit public license because it
just appears so often and it will assign
a single pattern um to this data point
down here
just because it's such an outlier right
so how do we
how do we devise a
scheme that will find this one reliably
but sort of will recognize wait a minute
this this memorization here is okay
um but we need to devise a scheme
without having access to the training
data right
um if a human looks at it of course the
mit public license is
you know seems common we know that it's
common
and so on we know that it's highly
likely text because it's a it's a
license almost everywhere
if a human looks at this right here and
sees you know the
name and address of a person or a credit
card number we know that's
not really highly likely text and that's
sort of the the answer right here so we
say if a human looks at it
but what is a human a human is just
another language model
among other things right but the human
is just sort of
another thing that has an intuition of
how how likely text is
so the basis of their approach is going
to be the following
let's take a second a second data set
okay sampled in the same way also from
the internet but not
in exactly the same way in fact they use
common crawl instead of the
the reddit outbound links that gpt2 used
but we take any other data set and i'm
going to draw the other data set so
here's the data point here's a data
point
maybe this data point is duplicated from
the other data set
and here's a data point here one right
so you you're going to have
um sort of other data points but also
you know since you're sampling from the
internet broadly you're going to have
the mit public license many times and
you're also going to have the outliers
in this
data set now the important part is
you're probably
if you sample this differently um in the
same fashion but a bit differently
you're probably not going to have
this same outlier right here you're
probably not going to have that
in your new data set okay so you can see
in the new data set
i i hope you can see this you're going
to have the the same
pattern extracted here even though it's
from you know slightly different data
points you're going to have maybe a
pattern extracted here
maybe one here you're going to have this
same cluster here because the mit public
license
will appear even though it comes from
other documents it's copied over and
over
and you're going to have this outlier
right here so
what you can do to differentiate our two
our two things you can consider
a second language model and you can ask
so here you have two things that the
first language model things are very
likely you have this thing right here
and you have this thing right here both
the first language model considers super
likely
you ask the second language model and
the second language module says
yes the mit public license i consider
that to be
also super likely but this outlier over
here now that's
i've never seen that what's that that
seems very unlikely
and so by the ratio of the two
likelihoods of the two different models
you can find out samples that
the first model finds super likely but
the second model
things are not likely at all
and that's exactly the trick they use
right here
in fact they use many instances of that
trick so here are the strategies
perplexity
is simply what they used before whatever
is likely is probably memorized
um this yes it's memorized but it's
often memorized justifiedly then they
have these strategies
small and medium and and this is the
ratio of the log perplexities
of the largest gpt-2 model that's the
one they attack
and the small gpt-2 model and this
ties into so you don't even need a
different model right you can simply
train
a the reason they train a smaller model
is the following um and we on the
machine learning street talk podcast if
you don't know that it's it's a it's a
podcast where we
talk to people from various you know
from the industry
and from various research labs and so on
and we
spoke with sarah hooker who
um we talked about their paper the
hardware lottery but she also has other
research
where she sort of shows that if you have
weights so you have a neural network and
it has you know layers
layers layers and you have weights in
these layers right
what she was able to show is that um
not all weights are equal so some of the
weights let's say the weights here
will be allocated to these pattern
extraction things so you know
here we have these you know you have
date training data training it to
outlier outlier right
so you'll have this you have these
weights representing this pattern within
a layer right you have
these this pattern will be represented
by
these weights right here and then you'll
have other weights
they're sort of allocated to remembering
single
or very few outliers
okay so here this will be allocated and
these will be disproportionate
so there will be many many more data
samples
covered by let's say this piece of
weights right here i should have drawn
the bottom one smaller
than by this so there there might be you
know a thousand training examples
covered by one piece of weight space and
there might be only
one piece of training data covered by
this other piece of weight space and
that's simply because it can
extract a pattern from one but not from
the other so it needs to memorize it
and the larger we make these models you
know the more
parameters we give them the more the
more
the more ability they have the more
space they have to do this remembering
so what what uh sarah hooker noticed in
in her paper is if you then distill
these models and distillation is the
process of taking these models
and putting their knowledge into smaller
models
then what happens is not all training
data points
will will so that in distillation you
usually lose performance
not all training data points will lose
performance equally
namely you will lose performance on the
training data points
that are sort of these outliers that are
these not
often represented in the training data
that you know the model has a harder
time
extracting a patterns from it so they
will be
um seldom patterns or just
hard patterns i would also assume that
you know patterns that are harder to
extract
will also fall fall away so the the more
complicated
patterns will also be sacrificed but i
guess
among the things are these outliers so
if you train a smaller model
the smaller model would have less
ability to remember
these outliers and therefore
if you do this you don't even have to do
it on a different training data set
right you can simply compare to the same
model trained on
uh sorry to a smaller version of the
same model
trained on the same training data set
because that will probably not remember
the outliers as much it would have been
interesting if these authors here had
actually distilled gpt
2 and though they do not have access to
the original training data so i can
get why they didn't do it but
it would be interesting to see that
that gives me an idea sort of
maybe there is actually a way to look at
the weights and i get these
these offers don't have access to the
weights but maybe there's a way to look
at the weights
and to actually be able to sort of in
some way
spot right which of the which of the
weights
only are associated with with single or
very few training data points maybe
during training you can sort of count
how many times a weight is updated in a
substantial amount or maybe looking at
the attention matrices you can sort of
determine
what are the kind of patterns that need
to happen that lead to this
weight being activated right so if
there's a weight and it's activated by
lots of lots of different patterns
um maybe you know that weight is useful
for many
many uh forward propagated signals but
if there is another weight that's only
activated by a specific
pattern right then maybe that's one of
these these memorization weights so
maybe there's a way to recognize these
in the weights
uh directly so distillation um
appears to be sort of a defense against
this this memorization
um of things though that's not
that's not done in this particular paper
they also have different strategies so
you don't need to do this neurally
right you can compare the ratio of the
perplexity that gpt2 gives
to the z-lib entropy so this is a simply
a text compression
method you can even compare it
perplexities between the original string
and the lowercase version
and so on so they extract for each of
these configurations we select 100
examples among the top
1000 samples so they produce a thousand
samples and they sample
100 from those thousands so they mostly
sample
from low ranked samples but also they
explore
some of the high ranked samples they
have a a formula
where they sample they de-duplicate and
then they
investigate all right so they do google
searches
if they can find the thing they say
that's memorized
right so they say across all strategies
what we identify
604 unique memorized training examples
from among the 1
800 candidates uh our best variant has a
true positive rate of 67 percent
that's quite remarkable right so 67
um 67 percent of the
things that this method delivers you
automatically
are actually memorized
though you have to qualify that right if
you want more than
a thousand examples that rate's gonna
drop
right you since you select the top 1000
examples these are the most likely to be
memorized
um so yeah if an attacker wants more if
they want to scale this attack up
their positive rate is gonna plummet uh
fairly quickly
i'm going to assume it would actually be
interesting also to see how that
develops
with the top the top
retrieved document right here but i get
the
they have to do google searches to
figure out and then ask openai to figure
out if
it's really a memorized training example
they say
they're categories we manually group the
memorized samples into different
categories
the results are shown in table one most
memorized content is fairly canonical
text from news headlines
log files entry from forums or wikis or
religious text
however we also identify a significant
amount of unique data
containing 128 bits uuids correctly
resolving
urls containing random strings and
contact information of individual people
okay so um as i said
these this is this is fairly interesting
but also a bit expected right
if i give you the start of a uuid um
then there is no pattern to extract
except i guess the uuid structure but
there is no
deeper pattern to exact so all the model
really can do is memorize the the uuid
especially if there aren't too many
uuids in the training data or if this
particular uuid
is some sort of as i said it's this
outlier type of situations
the same thing for you know urls
containing random strings
these are just not pattern extractable
therefore
easily more easily remembered by the
model than
learned so you can see
right here the breakdown where
they see how many of what they extract
and here contact info 32
named individuals in non-news
46 that's a fair amount of
things you can extract from gpg too
though you have to say that that is
all right all of gpt2 um
you get approximately a hundred
things that are kind of names or contact
informations so as i said
not too bad specifically considering uh
what i've shown you
here right um that's
one of these contact informations and
they do say this in the paper that this
pers this
information was obviously released in
the context
of this software project and the problem
is only the model might actually output
this in a different context right the
model might think
oh now i need to output some sort of
name and address
what kind of names and addresses do i
know well this name and address appears
pretty often i'm going to put that here
and
so that's a failure case you know that
these things
can do
so here is a sort of a graph
and they have more of these graphs later
but you can see that
here for example is a gpt-2 perplexity
and here is this z-lib entropy and if
you plot them one against another
most things will fall on this diagonal
right here with
you know the giant blob around here for
most texts of the internet
and there will be a region where
gpt2 thinks this is fairly low
perplexity
but zlib thinks the text is relatively
high entropy so these are candidates
for memorization and
the red and blue here are the ones the
authors selected
for checking and the ones that are blue
are
ones that they found or memorized from
the internet so a fairly high percentage
in fact
67 of this method that they selected
was in fact um was memorized
though as i said you can see that
there aren't super many more right so
this is
this is all samples and i don't know how
many you know
um they could generate more but you can
see that it gets pretty sparse out
here okay
yeah so examples of memorized content
personally identifiable information
they say there are several examples of
individual people's names phone numbers
addresses and social media accounts
some of this is memorized content is
just exclusive to a few
documents for example we extract the
user names of six users participating in
an irc conversation that happen
in exactly one document yeah so
i guess the question is how often did
the usernames appear in that one
document right and once the model sort
of
and how how distinct are these usernames
from
other usernames because if they're very
distinct and they happen you know they
have a long conversation
it can be easy to see that the model
will remember that
not saying this is not a problem i i'm
telling you
the models it's not it's not that
they'll just
randomly remember stuff there needs to
be very specific
conditions for the models to remember
stuff
so they say we identify 50 examples of
memorized urls that correctly resolve
to live web pages
okay many of these urls contain uncommon
pieces of text such as random numbers or
base64 encoded
strings again this this random element
right here
makes it you can't extract a pattern
they say we identify 31 generated
samples that contain snippets of
memorized source code
and they can actually extend that so
they can take these snippets and they
they always
i think they do 256 token lengths but
they can extend that
to sort of verbatim recover the source
code
and that's also you know that's that's
fairly interesting
um and unnatural text yeah these
uu ids uh a google search for this
string identifies just
three document containing this uuid and
it is contained in just
one gpt2 training document okay
though again we are not seeing how often
they say table three gives nine examples
of k equals one memorized content each
of which is a random sequence between 10
and 87 characters long
you can see the table right here so
these are examples of random strings
that for some reason appear
in this training data in exactly one
document
however this string right here for
example appears 10 times
and this string right here appears 311
times
so again it's a random string that
appears
though 10 times is fairly often for a
piece of text to appear especially the
same piece of text
that is not pattern close to any other
piece of text
it seems okay that the model remembers
that it seems expected
right so
yeah here they they also say data from
two sources
we find that samples that contain two or
more snippets of memorized text that are
unrelated to one another
in one example gpt2 generates a news
article about the real murder of a woman
in
2013 but then attributes the murder to
one of the victims of a nightclub
shooting in orlando in 2016.
and this i found very very interesting
right
because that's exactly what i said gpt3
does right especially
so in gpth3 they have this example of
gpt3
writing an entire news article about i'm
not even sure about some
pastors uh some split in the mormon
church or something like this
or i'm i don't remember correctly but i
was able to google that
and i did not find the verbatim sequence
but i found
that article that gpt3 wrote many many
times
in sort of different words in written
down in you know books and
reported about and so on uh so what gpt3
did is simply
i would guess interpolated between these
things
and here they find the same thing gpt2
um
just takes two pieces of text and sort
of finds that they're close and sort of
interpolates between the two
i would call this memorization two and
they say yeah there are
this is memorized text this is not
memorized text in their
definition of memorized text but it is
right so so it sort of mixes up
different training data points together
and
this i think is a strong um
it's very strong evidence for how these
language models
work in that they they sort of take
training data points
and they just kind of mix them together
and they can do this in a grammatically
well-founded fashion they can also
change individual
words of a sentence and so on by the way
it doesn't mean
that people are doing anything smarter
like there are arguments like the best
arguments i hear are you know people are
kind of doing the same thing they're
just kind of recount the training
samples in their
a bit of their own words um but yeah
this this i found extremely extremely
interesting
and also you know what i found from gpt3
with this google example was that the
problem of memorization may even be
way more way worse than what they
analyze in this paper right here
because they look for sort of direct
direct overlap in text where
as they wouldn't catch strings that are
you know
sort of reformulated
um again okay so here they
they lastly they say um
they can extend text and this thing here
i find very interesting so they say
if they if they put in this prompt
3.14159 gpd2 will complete the first
25 digits of pi correctly interestingly
when they input pi is this it gives
the first 799 digits
and if they say e is this and pi
is this then it gets the first 824
digits correctly so they make the point
here that the memorization problem could
actually be much worse
if you only knew uh what
prefix to input so this strengthens my
case
for the future job description of a
prompt
engineer right it seems to be that it's
quite a
sort of magical power to know what to
input into these language models to make
them
output what you want them to output in
this context but also in the context
where you actually want to do them
i want want them to do something useful
all right and here here is where they
investigate this number k
so you might have noticed and this is a
bit of the criticism of my paper
up until this point yes they have you
know they have the k
equals one right here and they sometimes
say that it's only found in very few
examples but
essentially they just they they um
they investigate this memorization here
pretty much in absence of k
of what they themselves define to be
problematic right they say well it's
problematic
if it only appears in few training
examples
but the the analysis here is done
quite absent of k very often
and here is where they investigate this
so
this is also pretty clever the the the
experiments here are fairly clever
um they find a
they find a one piece
one document a paste bin document
so the pastebin document
where that is sort of a json document
and
it has lots of links and i've i found
the document the giant document okay
and it's a john jason document with
these entries so there's this entry
there is color and then
link and then here the url would go on
right
and um it is the in fact the
the only document in the internet at
least these these authors claim
that uh contains these urls but
many of the urls are repeated many times
in fact um here you can see that these
are the continuations
of the urls right this one even though
it's contained in one document
it's actually repeated 359 times
and so on so this is a playground
they say okay this document was in the
training data of
gbt2 um here we
know how often each of these strings
appeared
in the document so they can directly
make an experiment
how often does a string need to be
present for the model
to memorize it they simply order
by the number of total occurrences right
here as you can see
and they ask each of these models
whether or not
it has memorized the string and
they do this by inputting this so this
is the input
and they simply sample if the model
manages to output any of these urls they
consider that to be
memorized if not then not
if it doesn't memorize it they have a
second trick that
if model can get half a point if they
input this first random sequence i think
they put six
tokens of this random sequence and if
then the model completes
then they say ah it has memorized it
right
so you can see right here it appears
that
the this large language model needs
this needs a string let's say 20 times
or higher
for it to memorize it and you can also
see the trend right here that if you go
to the smaller
models they need a lot more
in order to memorize them because they
have less weights they can't afford to
memorize
stuff easily right um they need to
extract the pattern so they'd rather
forget about the string incur a loss
and focus on other training examples
so yeah two things in this direction
smaller models in this direction larger
models
so that means that something like gpt3
will have this problem much more
pronounced
so that's the the bad news about this
result the good
news about this result is that this is
the case
where you have fairly random sequences
right these
uh even you know that if tokenizing this
is not going to be natural text
and there are these you know random
these reddit urls have these random
prefixes
uh so this is very much this sort of
outlier
case um it's a pretty clever case study
to find
this document i have to say but it is
sort of
good news um that
this is not the usual case this is
really the case
that this data is very very prone to
being memorized right because it's
not patternable and it's very random
and yeah so
okay so that was that was that
um as i said the amount of hedging
right here is is really really
uh like it's a lot um they discuss what
you can do
with it you can train with differential
privacy
though that doesn't really help as we
said because
some of these strings are included in
you know more than one time
you can curate the training data which
doesn't really help
because the training data is too large
um you can limit impact of memorization
on
downstream applications so if you
fine-tune but we don't know
exactly what fine-tuned models forget
and what they retain
or you can audit which is essentially
what this paper
paper right here does and that seems
like a that seems like uh
seems like a good you know the best
strategy we have so far is
is to audit these models and yeah
so i wanted to uh quickly
check out also the appendix the appendix
here shows sort of
these graphs for the other methods and
it is very cool if you want to you know
check that out
and it has sort of categorization of
what they
find as these memorized pieces of text
but what my main point was right here is
that this paper
shows a problem let's say
with these large language models namely
that they memorize
certain pieces of training data while
that sounds scary
i feel that the nature of the data that
it remembers is very particular so not
you cannot
extract any piece of training data the
nature is very particular
it's the sort of outlier-ish uh training
data points
and also it very very very often
it isn't enough that it just is
there one time so even when they say
this piece of information is only in one
document
very often it appears many times in that
um that together with the sort of
non-pattern ability of the data that it
memorizes right here
actually makes me fairly fairly
optimistic
more optimistic than i would have
thought honestly about these language
models yes so
we'll see what the future brings
as i said this is going to be more
pronounced in
larger models and this is not the only
problem with these models as my gpt3
google search in that video shows all
right
i hope this was enjoyable let me know
what you think and maybe check out the
paper
bye